mes chers amis ce conseil national
devait nous permettre de dire ce que
nous avons sur le coeur c'est un
exercice auquel nous ne nous livrons pas
souvent alors je vais vous dire ce que
j'ai sur le coeur
lorsque le général de gaulle reçoit à
londres les premiers français libres qui
ne sont encore que quelques-uns il leur
dit je ne vous félicite pas d'être venu
vous n'avez fait que votre devoir
ces quelques mots sont le plus bel
hommage jamais rendu à mes yeux à tous
ceux dont l'enseignement ne réclame
l'engagement pardon ne réclame pas
d'autres récompenses que l'austère
fierté de servir une cause plus grande
que soit cause d'une patrie est celle
d'une civilisation qui s'appelle toutes
deux la france comme un certain nombre
d'entre vous j'ai adhéré jeunes à une
famille politique qui se voulait
dépositaire de cette haute conception
morale de l'engagement
j'y retrouvais des femmes et des hommes
qui avaient toujours fait passer leur
pays avant leur parti
des hommes et des femmes qui avaient
leurs défauts qui avaient leurs
faiblesses humaines mais qui au moment
de choisir ne se demandent déjà mais où
était la droite où était la gauche où
était le centre mais où était l'intérêt
national au il leur arrivait de se
tromper mais il y avait une chose sur
laquelle il ne se trompait jamais
c'était le sens qu'il donnait à leur
engagement politique
les uns se souvenant qu'il avait jadis
dit non à tout ce qui menace d'asservir
un homme ou un peuple les autres qu'ils
étaient les successeurs de ceux qui
avaient opposé un destin pitoyable ce
refus obstiné cette famille elle
s'appelait le gaullisme non à cause
d'une idéologie mais à cause d'une
histoire une histoire qui parlait de
l'honneur de la liberté de la grandeur
d'un peuple
souvent on me dit c'est de l'histoire
ancienne
pour certains peut-être mais ironie de
l'histoire ce sont souvent les adeptes
des vieilles lunes de la politique
politicienne
le clientélisme les petits calculs pour
gagner à tout prix les élections sans se
soucier de la manière dont on gouvernera
demain la politique des mensonges
électoraux des slogans les petits
habiletés et les castings
gouvernementaux en guise de cache misère
d'une politique qui ne pense rien qui ne
veut rien sinon pour avoir l'air d'agir
démolir tout ce qu'elle peut font des
ravages dans l'esprit public
les politiciens n'ont pas compris que le
peuple en colère ne leur pardonnera plus
rien plus rien à vrai dire
à vrai dire mes chers amis au milieu des
grands désordres du monde je ne discerne
pas d'autre voie que celle tracée par la
leçon intellectuelle et morale du
gaullisme nous avons voulu faire le
rassemblement de la droite et du centre
et puisqu'on joue aujourd'hui on se dit
tout permettez moi d'exprimer un regret
je regrette ou et la disparition du rpr
je regrette la fin d'un mouvement
gaulliste se revendiquant comme tel dans
la vie politique française est radié
avec le centre oui gouverner avec le
centre oui bien sûr mais en voulant
organiser toute la vie démocratique
autour de deux grands partis l'un de
centre gauche le ps l'autre de
centre-droit à l'ump
nous avons commis une faute l'identité
de chacun s'en est trouvée affaiblie au
lieu de se rassembler les électeurs se
sont dispersés à ceux qui croient
aujourd'hui que la france peut être
gouverné au centre je veux dire que la
situation matérielle et morale de notre
pays rend cette aspiration chimérique
à ceux qui croient à ceux qui croient à
ce qu'ils croient voir la france se
droitiser et qui rêve qu'elle soit
gouverné le plus à droite possible
quelle droite d'ailleurs
parmi tant de droite qui ne se sont
jamais aimé qu'ils n'ont jamais partagé
grand-chose droite dure droite molle
droite morale droite de l'argent droite
libérale libertaire conservatrice
autoritaire et socratique populaire a
toutes ces droite je veux dire qu'il ne
faut pas confondre la radicalisation
avec la droitisation parce que ce n'est
pas du tout la même chose parce que la
radicalisation ne se reconnaît ni dans
la droite ni dans la gauche
les apprentis sorciers de l'arithmétique
électorale qu'ils croyaient être moderne
en escamotant le gaullisme en tout
simplement ramené nous ont tout
simplement ramené à la fin de la
quatrième république ou de la troisième
vous savez quand les petits abandons et
les grandes lâchetés préparer les grands
naufrages de reconnaissons d'ailleurs
reconnaissons le
ce qu'ils ont vécu le savent bien le
parti gaulliste à l'intérieur du parti
du parti gaulliste à l'intérieur du rpr
il y avait aussi le parti de
l'antigaullisme et il faudra bien mes
chers amis qu'un jour ou l'autre
l'histoire soit appelé à rendre à chacun
son dû
prenons le gaullisme pour ce qu'il est
réellement non une nostalgie mais la
grande exigence politique de notre temps
la grande exigence morale et politique
de notre temps je ne suis pas de je ne
sais quelle droite je ne suis pas
centriste
je ne suis pas libéral je ne suis pas né
aux conservateurs je suis gaulliste je
crois à l'indépendance nationale et à la
souveraineté du peuple et j'en ai assez
quand les abîmes mois moi ma famille
politique ce n'est pas le ppe dont nous
avons si soigneusement caché le
programme pendant les élections
européennes
parce que nous ne pouvions pas l'assumer
devant les français moi ma famille
politique ce n'est pas celle d'un
président de la commission européenne
qui a dirigé pendant des années le plus
grand système d'évasion fiscale d'europe
- ma famille politique ce n'est pas
celle qui veut plus de fédéralisme en
europe
moi ma famille politique ce n'est pas
celle qu'ils n'imaginent d'autre destin
à la france
que de devenir soi demande soit anglo
saxon moi ma famille politique
moi ma famille politique elle veut
l'amitié franco allemande
mais elle ne veut pas de la
subordination de la france à l'allemagne
elle veut l'alliance de la france et de
l'amérique mais elle ne veut pas de
l'inféodation de la france à l'amérique
moi moi mes chers amis ma famille
politique c'est celle qui prend à bras
le corps la plus grande crise financière
de tous les temps et pas celle qui fait
entrer la finance partout merci nicolas
moi ma famille politique ce n'est pas
celle qu'ils se rallient à la politique
des dîners en ville d'un ministre de
l'économie qui confond la banque
d'affaires avec la politique de la
france
oui j'en ai assez j'en ai assez
d'entendre dire monsieur macron ac a
adhéré laquelle adhérait aux
républicains non moi je n'en veux pas
dans ma famille politique
moi moi moi ma famille politique
ma famille politique c'est celle qui a
honte d'entendre un ministre de la
république française s'exprimer en
anglais à davos devant tous les
banquiers du monde pour leur dire que la
situation économique ne permet pas de
payer un peu plus les heures
supplémentaires de ceux qui travaillent
le plus
le plus dur pour essayer de faire vivre
leur famille moi ma famille politique
c'est celle qui refuse de dresser toutes
les catégories de français
les unes contre les autres de faire la
politique des boucs émissaires
un jour les fonctionnaires un autre jour
les médecins
un jour les chômeurs un jour les
salariés un jour les patrons un jour les
taxis un jour les notaires les
pharmaciens ou les retraités
un jour les religions un autre les
origines et demain quoi la lutte des
classes les guerres de religion la
guerre des mémoires
ça va s'arrêter quand ça va s'arrêter
avant la guerre de tous contre tous ou
après c'est ça la morale de la politique
moi ma famille politique c'est celle
qui ne dira jamais un ouvrier de 50 ans
qui a travaillé toute sa vie qui a
encore trois enfants à élever et dont
l'entreprise vient de partir en chine
parce que nos politiques et les
politiques européennes sont folles qu'il
est un feignant parce qu'ils ne trouvent
pas de travail
moi ma famille politique c'est celle qui
ne dira jamais à cet officier supérieur
qui a quitté l'armée après avoir servi
son pays pendant 30 ans pour travailler
dans une entreprise qui a fait faillite
et qui me raconte qu'il ne retrouve pas
de travail parce que lui aussi a plus de
50 ans ma famille politique c'est celle
qui ne lui dira jamais qu'il est un
profiteur tout ce qu'il ya de petits
tout ce qu'il y a c'est tout ce qu'il ya
de plus grand dit peggy moi ma famille
politique c'est celle qui ne prendra
jamais l'enfant en otages de la
politique
moi ma famille politique c'est celle qui
trouve honteux que l'on puisse interdire
de cantine les enfants des chômeurs sous
le prétexte que leurs parents ne
travaille pas chez celles qui ne refuse
pas des enfants un repas de substitution
sans caractère religieux à la cantine
parce que je ne serai jamais d'accord
pour qu'on ne respecte pas les enfants
mois
moi mon idéal c'est le travail le mérite
l'excellence mais mon souci
mon souci c'est le sort des plus humbles
des plus vulnérables des plus fragiles
- mon souci c'est que la vie ne soit pas
que de la compétition et que de la
tension - ma morale c'est celle qui
m'interdit de dire aux français vous
savez si la situation de la france est
si difficile aujourd'hui c'est parce que
vous avez trop bien vécu depuis 40 ans
parce que c'est un mensonge
et parce que c'est une honte - ma
révolte c'est de voir à quel point on se
moque du monde
quand on prétend sauver notre
agriculture où notre industrie sans
s'attaquer de front aux concurrences
déloyales au dumping de toutes sortes à
l'intérieur même du marché unique sans
remettre en cause les politiques
européennes ni les politiques de
restriction du pouvoir d'achat qui
pousse désespérément le consommateur
vers le moins cher qui engendre la
déflation détruit notre économie notre
protection sociale et notre société - ma
révolte c'est de voir le marasme de la
france rurale à laquelle on promet des
secours sans vouloir mettre en oeuvre
remettre en oeuvre une vraie politique
d'aménagement du territoire
sans vouloir arrêter de fermer tous les
hôpitaux toutes les gendarmeries toutes
les écoles
oui moi ma révolte c'est de voir à quel
point on se moque du monde en promettant
de venir à bout du chômage de masse et
des déficits avec des catalogues de
mesures qui ont toujours échoué et qui
ne font qu'aggraver les désordres de
l'économie et de la société
alors que ce sont ces désordres qui
détruisent des emplois et qui creusent
les déficits
moi ma révolte c'est de voir la dérive
d'une justice dont le corporatisme le
syndicalisme l'idéologie et parfois oui
parfois libre s de la toute-puissance
mines l'état et la république au risque
de s'engager sur la pente fatale qui fut
celle des parlements de l'ancien régime
et de ruiner l'état de droit par les
aléas et l'arbitraire des jurisprudences
qu'elles soient familiales
sociale ou pénale sous estimer les
conséquences de cette dérive vers un
gouvernement des juges c'est une faute
grave peut-être la faute la plus grave
moi ma famille politique c'est celle qui
ne veut plus ni des munich sociaux comme
disait philippe séguin ni aidé munich
économique qui nous ont conduits là où
nous en sommes
- ma famille politique c'est celle qui
ne veut plus de l'inquisition fiscale
sociale environnementale qui étouffe
toutes les libertés montre ma famille
politique c'est celle qui veut la
liberté de conscience et de culte mais
qui ne veut pas changer de civilisation
qui ne pas changer de culture qui ne
veut à aucun prix de la société
multiculturelle et qui veulent
assimilation qui veut qu'à l'école on
étudie les croisades
on étudie la soie on étudie voltaire et
que l'on se découvre dans les salles de
classe et dans les salles de travaux
dirigés
moi ma famille politique c'est celle qui
ne peut pas laisser en suspens la
question si grave de la filiation
c'est celle qui ne veut pas d'une
société au tout ce qui n'a pas de prix
n'a plus de valeur d'une société où tout
devient une marchandise
même un enfant moi ma famille politique
c'est celle qui n'accepte ni les
communautés ni les tribus ni les
principautés ni les féodalités c'est
celle pour laquelle il n'ya ni peuple
corse ni peuple breton ni peuple
provençal ni peuple basque ni peuple
alsacien ni peuple picard mais un seul
peuple le peuple français
un seul peuple avec une seule langue
officielle le français - ma famille
oui c'est le gaullisme nationale
humaniste tournée vers le grand large et
plus à france des faits
et plus je suis gaulliste et plus je
suis jacobins et plus je suis
colbertiste et plus je suis
assimilationniste oui pauliste jacobins
colbertiste assimilationniste et pour le
retour de la nation et du peuple dans la
politique
oui et je l'assumé l'effacement mes
chères amies et chers amis je ne demande
à personne de renier son histoire
politique et ses engagements mais je
demande à chacun de réfléchir à ceux ci
l'effacement de l'identité gaulliste
dans la politique n'a produit qu'une
seule chose la radicalisation de la
société et la montée des extrêmes
je ne peux plus je ne veux plus me
résigner à vous de choisir entre la
force du nom dans l'histoire qui
s'appelle le gaullisme et qui est en
réalité un oui à la volonté à la liberté
humaine et la voie de la tyrannie
insidieuse du désordre de la servitude
dissimulé derrière ce que l'on nomme
prudemment nécessité de s'adapter parce
que l'on n'a même pas le courage de dire
subir vouloir ou subir se donner les
moyens d'agir dans le monde tel qu'il
est ou accepter de n'être que la
variable d'ajustement ou la victime
expiatoire de toutes les autres volonté
qui s'exprime dans le monde
le gaullisme ou le renoncement demain la
france ou l'europe du moyen âge